fille on Savit pas si va tervenir en
prison à l'Élysée bon Macron c'est une
bulle
euh économique et médiatique qui va
faire savezun moment à l'ut mélanchant
et amant vont se cannibaliser du verbe
c'est un verbe du premier groupe qui
veut dire se se manger gravement si vous
étiez pas candidat vous auriez soutenu
Philippe houtou vous auriez voté pour
non mais je lu donné mon parrainage mais
c'est une affaire sérieuse je l'ai
parrainé c'est peut-être grâce à moi qui
s'est qualifié h et vous imaginez quand
même c'est pas tout le monde qui fait ça
voilà bon bon voilà c'est pour expliquer
comment je je veux que les choses se se
passent j'ai besoin de VOUS j'ai besoin
de toi de chacun d'entre toi j'ai besoin
de tous les toit j'ai besoin de vous
tous vive la République vive la
France